we're learning about a growing effort to
save a struggling Chinatown New York
City's original Chinatown believe it or
not is its severe risk of Disappearing
that's according to a report last year
tourism is down rents are up and there
is no line of succession for many
businesses there is one exception though
it is called wing on woe which means
forever peaceful and safe it is the
oldest continuously run shop in their
neighborhood it dates back folks to
1890. wow and I'm at the owner who
turned down an ivy league university to
keep the shop in her family and now
she's trying to help save her beloved
neighborhood for future Generations
[Music]
amid the flurry of New York City's
Chinatown
there's a place where time seems to turn
back
this single room shop at 26 Mott Street
is wing on woe and Co the oldest
continuously run business in the
neighborhood
[Music]
family run store is known for its
porcelain Goods especially tea sets
sourced directly from China these
bulldogs and monkeys were sourced from
Hong Kong during my grandmother's time
May long is its fifth generation owner
and while she aims to preserve the
Legacy her family has built here she's
also breathing new life into it by
expanding its inventory we wanted to
work with different artists to create
reinterpretations of old patterns
thank you
[Music]
for presents
including turning its previous owner her
Grandma Nancy side into a social media
sensation what's your favorite tea lump
took the reins from her grandmother
seven years ago what's your first memory
of the shop
I grew up coming here kind of being
dropped off after school and running to
the back kitchen and spending time with
my grandparents and then I would run out
into the front to run the cash register
if there was a customer who came in my
memories are really
focused and centered around family even
though this is a place of business this
was never a job yeah it was more of a
space to understand my own cultural
identity and it's been a challenge to
understand how to breathe new life into
this space too and make it my own
Chinatown had cobblestone streets and
one carriages Gary Lum is May's dad he
bought us a few blocks down to where
wing on woe first opened in 1890.
through the years it's evolved alongside
the Chinatown Community it's gone
through different iterations over time
it was a Buddhist temple as a postal
drop off it was a social Gathering Place
we moved over to this location in 1925
and then that's when we expanded our
operation we had an in-house herbalist
we had a roasting Pig pit in the back
and then fast forward to 1964 was when
my grandmother took over and was like oh
I'm not going to chop me I'm done and
decided to focus on porcelain was there
resistance to that or was it seen as the
Natural Evolution of things her father
had a sudden heart attack in the shop
and they had to make a decision about
what they were going to do with the
space and she decided that she didn't
want to let it go 52 years later Lum
found herself at similar Crossroads I
got a call from my dad and he was like
you know we're considering selling the
story just wanted to let you know my
grandmother was getting up in age and I
don't think anybody in my family was
really willing to take on the reins or
fill those shoes everybody was like okay
well it's been nice it's been it's been
a great run
my grandma was like I'm never gonna walk
down my street again
I can't it's too painful I just wanted
to not only keep wing on what going but
keep my family living room keep a space
for my elders to age in place that was
number one they decided not to sell the
business and it stayed in the family
under lum's leadership leadership that
now focuses on saving America's
chinatowns I hear from everybody that
they're concerned that the neighborhood
is gentrifying very quickly so I decided
okay maybe there's something within my
own capacity that I could take on for a
crny artists we're going to hold
one-on-ones the first week of July so
I'm founded the wow project a non-profit
using arts and activism to resist
gentrification and protect businesses
like wing on woe I think what keeps us
here in Chinatown is definitely the fact
that there are small family-owned
businesses that are here and have been
here since the 1920s and chinatown's
early Beginnings can you see yourself
here for the next 40 years or I think
I'm trying to be present
pushing the bounds of what a suffering
can be in a neighborhood like it can be
a place of Storytelling cultural
production politicization and whoever's
interested in taking that over a family
member or not I think I am excited by
[Music]
so one of the things that I love about
the story is not just because of the
porcelain which we which we have in our
own home but I just love this idea of a
young person sort of rejecting the self
and her own interest to protect
something that means so much to our
family and the community at large it's
not just her own family she sees all the
businesses and the business owners in
Chinatown is part of her family and sort
of rejecting the one thing that can make
me successful I can go to Columbia
University and do other things become a
banker or whatever she wants to do
instead I'm going to go and run this
shop but it sounds like she's doing
exactly what she wants to do and doesn't
regret that decision yeah it's a big
decision yeah for sure and her you know
you walk in there her grandmother's
still there her dad is behind the
counter uh there's aunts and uncles and
everybody coming in and going coming and
going it's a really beautiful space
that's a great Point instead of cutting
ties or actually weaving those ties more
deeply yeah may seem like a tall task
but Legacy is on the line that's right